moving on
our main story tonight concerns local
news the trusted place people go to find
traffic whether and here in new york the
single greatest 10 seconds of television
this city has
ever produced at 11 pay more at the
grocer but getting less we'll tell you
how to get the most
the are you doing
perfect absolutely perfect that is
sue simmons by the way she sadly retired
in 2012 and has been missed
every day since because if any city
needs a news anchor with an ability to
say
the are you doing it is new york
we've talked about local news a lot on
this show particularly regarding just
how
important it is to any community we are
constantly featuring
local news investigations in our stories
and it isn't just important in a civic
sense
it's a major money maker for stations
nexstar one of the biggest owners of
local stations said they earned nearly
half their advertising revenue
from spots aired during local news
programming but the need to both
inform a community and make money has
always been tricky to reconcile
as you can tell from this 1960s clip of
baltimore's channel 11 news
in chicago today white mobs threw rocks
and bottles at civil rights
demonstrators
that story after this message about
mash's ham
he's a lover no not the kind you're
thinking of he's a ham lover
and all ham lovers know that mash's hams
are the best you can buy
okay that is a very awkward transition
to have to make
to go from teasing a story about a
racist mob with a mash's ham logo on
your desk
to a man who is no matter what he says
definitely that ham
which is absurd why would you do that
when instead you could be
honeysuckle white's fresh ground turkey
the only ground turkey that's 93
lean and 100 get your phil
with honeysuckle now clearly maintaining
journalistic independence from
advertisers is
critically important so important in
fact it's frequently referred to as
the church state war and the fcc has
rules requiring broadcast stations to
announce
when content has been sponsored or paid
for in any way
unfortunately many local stations have
either completely broken those rules
or violated the spirit of them through a
practice known as
sponsored content it's where advertising
is blended
directly into the broadcasts and it's
both more widespread
and harder to detect than you might
realize so tonight
let's talk about sponsored content and
let's start with the stuff
that seems essentially harmless people
getting paid to
hawk products on tv there is an industry
of lifestyle experts that do this and
here is one of them
explaining the process to potential
clients brand integration
is where a brand its product and the
messaging are all
worked together within the content of a
show in a pre-planned manner with so
many shows
offering integrated content it can be
hard to choose but let's start with
local okay we have a method that helps
me get interviews in a snap
hi michelle hey there jer bear
hi michelle hey girl how you doing
see in an instant we have access to
shows across the nation
that are ready for your content wow i
gotta say that
is pretty impressive the only person i
can summon with a snap of my fingers
is george clooney watch there he is
hello hey george how you doing
i'm doing fine what are you doing
i'm just showing people how i can summon
you with a simple snap of my fingers
um i'm eating dinner
i gave you that power in a limited
capacity john
understood george bye bye
see the system works but the truth is
michelle didn't just have the power to
make people appear out of thin air she
also crucially
had the power to make them play along as
she hawked horrifying products like
these
these are the new french's crispy
jalapenos
one fun idea is to use it in this
jalapeno
cheeseburger dip this is seriously
everything you love about a cheeseburger
in dipped form take a look is this thing
gorgeous or what so this has just hit
the party scene
it's the velveeta shells and cheese
life-sized
liquid gold fountain okay so a few
things i love are doritos
melted cheese sticks and nachos and now
there is a way you can enjoy them all in
one
these are doritos loaded it is a totally
new way to experience doritos
that's a really fun twist on a snack
idea isn't it
no no it isn't now that product has
since been discontinued probably because
it looks less like a snack and more like
someone deep fried a fidget spinner
and you probably assumed michelle was
getting paid to do that but
interestingly
the station was also getting paid to
have her
on and while the fcc requires sponsored
content like that to be labeled it has
no requirements for exactly how or for
how long
so for instance in the case of doritos
loaded the disclosure came at the very
end of the segment for just two seconds
with another barely visible reference in
the credits at the end of the program
for four more so six seconds total
which is incidentally about the same
amount of time doritos loaded stay
in your body before being forcibly
ejected from whatever orifice they're
closest to
this practice can be so lucrative that
many big chains have now set up
templates for local shows
built around sponsored content scripps
has
morning blend tegner has great day
next star has daytime and sinclair has
what i can only assume is
the muslims attack at dawn and it's not
just brand experts joining by satellite
sometimes local businesses will pay for
an interview where they can script the
questions
and make sure that they're presented
glowingly take jim hefner until recently
he was a financial advisor in charlotte
north carolina who was on the local show
morning break all the time and always
introduced in very positive terms
we have jim heffner he is a certified
financial planner
he's the president and ceo of hefner
financial he's a best-selling author
and just an all-around great guy thank
you so much mr hefner for being back
here you're regular here
thank you so much sir for being back
with us you're welcome we like when
you're here
we're so glad to have you back because
you're going to help our folks get
financially fit
welcome back mr hefner we love when you
are here with us sir this man knows
his stuff that level of enthusiastic
co-signing seems pretty convincing until
you remind yourself
the station was being paid to say those
things about him it's the reason
no one who gets a birthday cameo from
gary busey thinks
wow gary busey hopes i make it to 156
years old
he must be my best friend instead they
think
wow craig just wasted 350
getting gary beauty to wish me a happy
birthday he must be my best friend
and it's worth noting that hefner and
the firm he worked for not only were
ordered to pay a million dollars in an
arbitration case over claims he lost
retirees money
but 22 plaintiffs recently sued him
seeking damages related to the loss of
2.7 million
of their investments with one of them
even saying that he trusted hefner
because he believed the longest running
charlotte station
would invite on trusted experts and yeah
of course you would believe that people
trust their local station
that's the point here and it doesn't
stop
at these local lifestyle shows companies
have also bought their way
directly into local news broadcasts back
in 2017
sinclair faced a 13.3 million dollar
fine from the fcc
over segments promoting the huntsman
cancer institute which were broadcast
more than a thousand times on local
sinclair stations
with no indication whatsoever that they
were sponsored
some of these segments aired during the
evening news and in hindsight
the tone of the reports were
suspiciously upbeat
this complex machine is eradicating
cancer without the invasive procedures
for patients like jeff this is welcome
news if you're going to have prostate
cancer
this is the time to have it in salt lake
city utah mark cabell reporting
that is a hell of a positive spin no
time like the president to have prostate
cancer
what are you waiting for and despite how
he signed off there
is mark cabell actually reporting
because in retrospect it seems more like
mark cabell is parroting the absurdly
sunny cancer propaganda of his business
daddy's favorite money friend
but i will say this at least that is an
instance of a broadcaster acting
so egregiously the fcc was able to take
action
a lot of the time stations are doing
just enough
to stay the right side of the fcc but
that does not mean
that they're not doing massive harm to
their credibility because
even when a sponsorship is properly
disclosed
i'd argue that there are certain
businesses local stations should not be
selling themselves out for
especially when it comes to medicine
because a surprising number of segments
on these shows
are enthusiastic uncritical showcases
for expensive treatments or devices
featuring claims that are
to put it charitably medically dubious
like this product which made it onto a
regular morning newscast in utah
today we're talking about technology
aimed to help men with a serious
issue stephanie and dustin wolf the
co-inventors of the world's first
clinically tested
home use shockwave device to treat
electile dysfunction and cellulite it's
called the rocket this is the rocket so
the rocket
works on the principle of low intensity
sound wave therapy
which is actually been around in europe
for about 25 years
it's very effective um it's safe and uh
it's the technology is fda recognized
okay first that vibrating taint missile
looks utterly terrifying
and while it has since been rebranded
from the rockets to the phoenix
i'm not sure put this bird that destroys
itself in fire near your penis
is really much of an upgrade but second
what does
fda recognized even mean there it
definitely does not mean it's fda
cleared
much less approved and the fda actually
told us the phoenix is
registered with them as a therapeutic
massager though
not as a device to treat erectile
dysfunction and at this point
i legally have to tell you the
manufacturer of the phoenix
says they make no explicit claims about
treating ed
which is a little odd because their own
website claims the phoenix offers
proven technology to make your penis
harder and that
you can complete this innovative ed
treatment in the privacy of your home
all of which they presumably feel
justifies its price tag of
holy 879
but that is not the point here the point
is if you are going to allow that
product into the body of your local
newscast
you might want to have some very pointed
questions ready and not
end the segment like this of course if
you want to get more information where
they find it online guys oh they can go
to getmyrocket.com there you go
get that help you need for whatever
ailment you've got right there
yeah use the rocket for whatever ailment
you've got especially if that ailment is
having let's say
around 879 too many dollars
and the thing is that is far from the
only weird medical product that's been
presented
uncritically during sponsored segments
denver's mile high living featured a spa
owner promoting this exciting new
treatment
monalisa touch is the first fda cleared
laser to treat the vagina and in doing
so it treats the symptoms of vaginal
atrophy so the procedure itself is it
painful
no it's typically what you'll feel are
mild vibrations
i tease the next day you might feel like
you have a sunburned vagina but
it's just healing oh that's okay then
it's just your typical
everyday sunburned vagina and only
caused by a laser so
really just your typical everyday laser
roasted genitalia which is just healing
from the laser you deliberately burned
it with it being
the inside of your vagina your
run-of-the-mill laser charred vagina
and if using a laser as a medical pseudo
dildo
seems like a scary thing to do you have
good instincts
because over a year before that segment
aired the fda issued a safety alert
making it clear that they have
not cleared or approved for marketing
any energy-based devices to treat
vaginal atrophy
and applying energy-based therapies to
the vagina may lead to vaginal burns
scarring and recurring or chronic pain
and the problem is
segments with dicey medical claims are
just everywhere
recently the fda has warned about the
use of unapproved stem cell therapies
which they say
can be harmful but you would not know
that to watch some of these shows
here is a segment from good morning
texas featuring a doctor who's been
disciplined
multiple times by the state medical
board for separate issues
claiming his stem cell therapy can treat
things like ms
and parkinson's despite the fact that
stem cells have
never been approved to treat any
neurological disorder and it's not just
him
here is a naturopathic doctor making
similarly baseless claims on a station
in arizona
so what kind of conditions are you
treating with this so we can treat so
many
different kinds of conditions we can do
it the joints have been doing a lot of
that we do a lot of
systemic things as well including had a
patient with crohn's disease recently
had a patient with heart disease who was
in severe heart failure
both of them within a week of getting
these stem cells are just feeling great
and improved to almost normal wow yeah
wow indeed that card there suggested he
can treat parkinson's alzheimer's autism
ms and als it seems the only thing his
stem cells can't do
is help that station proofread their
list of conditions can stem cell therapy
benefits because
other than that got you they covered
have
and look while there is no way of
knowing exactly how many people are
watching these shows as they air
that's not really the point as this
marketing executive
at nexstar explained to potential
advertisers
now here's the deal most people think
okay so i go on the tv show i'm on tv
great this is awesome and
airs at four o'clock i go on and great
and people sing me okay so this is cool
i'm going to tell you right now when you
actually go on and do that
that isn't even the cake that's just the
icing
you know the cake is
the video file at the end you're gonna
have a four or five minute video file
and you're gonna do what with it post it
everywhere
okay first of all what is that motion
that is unnecessarily gross this isn't
how you represent cake and icing
this is how you bring a mash's ham to
orgasm you give it the old wiggle and
squeeze and then a twist
and a snap oh what is it
sorry george i'm sorry that one was
genuinely an accident i was just trying
to
show people how to bring a mash's ham to
orgasm that's not how you do it
oh
i guess that's good information to have
the point is though that marketing
executive
is right the cake is the video file
and companies will take that video and
run with it remember that naturopathic
doctor who claims stem cells are a
treatment for alzheimer's and autism
here is his website which proudly
features the many times he was given an
uncritical platform
on trusted local tv and you might think
viewers should be smart enough to
approach anything on these shows with
skepticism the thing is though
many of these stations also swap figures
between their newsroom
and their sponsored content shows at abc
4 utah for instance suray chin
is both the channel's chief medical
correspondent and
a host of the sponsored content show
good things utah
and it really does feel like a line is
getting blurred there
and look ideally stations wouldn't
engage in this practice at
all or at the very least their
disclosures would be harder for their
viewers to miss and
they do significantly more work to make
sure that if they are letting someone
buy their way onto their channel and
present something as
real that it's not in fact total
nonsense
because right now it's far too easy to
make a ridiculous product
that makes outlandish claims and get it
onto local tv
and the reason i know that is we did
we started a company called venus
inventions and created something called
the venus fail an absurd medical product
based on technology
that absolutely doesn't exist we set up
this website and even hired an actress
to brandigrate the
out of the venus veil into shows it had
no business being on
did it work i don't know you tell me
abc for utah i am so excited to talk
with erica hernandez
with the venus veil a revolutionary new
product on the line
what exactly is it i'm so intrigued i'm
so glad you are intrigued so this is the
venus veil
it is the world's first sexual health
blanket
yep that was on abc 4 last friday and i
would
love to tell you that it was difficult
to get on but it really wasn't
and remember that's their chief medical
correspondent and it seems striking
that she didn't have any follow-ups on
claims that we made about the veil
that you would hope a medical
correspondent would immediately take
issue with
the veil is being designed with the hope
that it will precisely draw out the
natural alkaline
undercurrents of the vagina and initiate
a low grade state of what we call
micro death which sounds incredibly
scary
but that's actually just restarting that
area's natural life cycle
it's using this field of magnetogenetics
i was talking about and also
a technology that's been around for a
really long time that was pioneered in
germany about 80 years ago so this is
full of cutting-edge technology but it
just looks like a blanket
yeah it does and that's because it is
it is just a blanket also technology
that was pioneered in germany about 80
years ago
i would have some questions about that
particular period in german history
and i know that looks bad but let's be
fair here it's just an isolated example
there was no way
another station was going to fall for
this right absolutely no way
is there cave you austin because you
wouldn't have let us pay to directly
follow your 10 pm local news this
thursday would you
there's no way that happened it includes
some pretty interesting technology
yes it does so the team behind the veil
was inspired by the field of
magnetogenetics but basically
your blood is full of iron but it's
dispersed in such a way that it isn't
affected by normal magnets
so the idea behind the veil is that with
the right blend of proprietary magnetic
fibers you can create a self-contained
magnetic field that re-stimulates blood
flow and gets you feeling like your
normal self again
very interesting is it is it interesting
or is that obvious that
definitely shouldn't have been on in the
same hour of coverage as
the ceasefire in the middle east a
shortage of lifeguards in local public
pools
and an investigative piece on criminal
justice and bail reform
one of these things is not like the
others and it's definitely
our nazi era blanket but surely
if you saw this blanket in person in a
studio
then you would know not to
enthusiastically co-sign on the
completely
baseless claims being made right in
front of you you would protect your
viewers from that happening
wouldn't you denver's mile high living
this is meant to treat sexual conditions
but a lot of people are really
embarrassed to talk about their sexual
health right so
it was designed to be something that's
really discreet and also really stylish
so you can have it in your home and it
really
i mean could it look less like a medical
product yeah no it doesn't look like
that
you know again it's one of those things
i think a lot of people right now are
looking to
enhance their lives but they also don't
want anything too invasive so
this is something where again you're not
needing a prescription or anything like
that as well
well thank you erica thanks so much for
coming in today we appreciate it thank
you so much for having me thanks for
making it so easy
yeah super easy yeah super easy
you can even argue way too easy because
the truth is
none of this was nearly difficult enough
to get onto tv
and it wasn't even that expensive that
cost just twenty eight hundred dollars
this one cost 26.50 and this one only
cost seventeen hundred
and fifty dollars it was all shockingly
affordable and sadly on some stations
didn't even look that out of place and
that is not good
because as we have said for years now
the integrity of local news
is crucially important and there is real
harm for
everyone if that integrity is damaged
so to the owners of these stations who
are selling them out at a depressingly
cheap price
i have a simple question if i may quote
the words of a
very wise news anchor the are you
doing that's our show thank you so much
for watching if you want to see our
venus veil segment in full
the whole cake if you will you can go to
venusinventions.com
good night
you